hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to rocket League with
Wade here how are you doing so we are
playing Morgan and this time he's gonna
be weird and he's gonna be on the other
team though so I won't have to deal with
his weirdness so you're gonna be orange
I'm gonna be sure orange I'm blue he's
orange so we're gonna be playing against
each other yes god that is so ugly your
car so and the reason we're playing on
the story just stop the ball the reason
playing on the story map is because it's
currently thunderstorm out right now
which I haven't seen in we've actually
lost power girl on so put all those
powers oh don't say that it's gonna
happen now okay alright so anyway we're
gonna play one more round I know I know
I know we're uh we can't play online
against each other so we're playing BOTS
again but this time they're dumb down to
pro level dumb down not unfair I swear
those guys were teleporting in the
lesson yes they were oh yeah oh dude oh
dude stupid I know but he's dude I was
in here you're like the rogue element
you're like talking sorry I'm not
grunting four one attack directly in my
ear also I should mention get out of
here play on now
you don't have all this magic of editing
is that I can do it later her locator
it's okay you scored one it was good you
did I drew ya did good you did good
oh yes your beard a nerd okay here we go
we are going to scare okay get it
straight get huge of hearing that's in a
long time
no beard if your name it's mighty just
sweet shirt
oh my gosh backwards can I do this
backwards
yeah what's this [ __ ] Oh trick shot damn
it beasts like actually say words you
know and come on with mom this is my
enemy how do you be that you do Let's
Plays for a living how do you not know
much like this where I don't drop much
and it's brunt I mean I can't talk about
so I was just doing the Swedish Chef
before this you know he's been in car
yeah I forgot your pink to that watching
achieve on just please say word Oh
celebrate with yeah yeah I did it
I scored gold moment area of epic
proportions courses alright I'm going to
go into trade you hit it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
now you really are doing solutions I am
going to kill kids I am doing I am one
of them young eaters no we do not hit me
that beers too feared in bicycle kickin
of fury is this offensive probably
extremely damn it levena what did you
know the spongebob episode was on
yesterday with the forbidden vengeance
and smearing smitty werben jaegerman
yeah that's the name spirit is this
cousin I still don't think you did it
right yeah I stole how does it feel like
I'm still how does it feel like you
penetrated my goal I have like a nose
here that's ticking I think one of my
moustaches nose hair is getting up into
my nose yeah it's a screen yeah yeah
what how was it it's funny because we
literally just saw each other last week
at VidCon I know he's like I'm in two
days I would say it's kind of reminds me
of how it was back before I left for LA
damn it I just realized text was
actually saving they put me on the
ceiling at least you weren't blown to
smithereens yeah it was a broke rule do
commentary nice shot nice shot national
I got this No
okay good good goal good wait nice shot
I got it oh my god I got it I got a
chance table for four second because
damn it sir great pass I'm such a tool
yeah oh sorry dude oops I got a first
touch though
maverick its Tex he's from Texas no
surprise because I don't expect death to
be a part of this I'm Billy
we're having fun awesome instant death
and form the family oh oh oh I'm still
on the ceiling okay coming back you need
to stop playing on your ceiling man you
know when they say play the field that's
what you need to do it's much more fun
when we play against each other right
now especially when I win right I heard
it you got 30 seconds to score I don't
know if you can do it though I'm all
baby all right get this 30 seconds oh do
you have anything to do with this one I
got you out of the way though
I don't know I just I was like going to
scratch my nose to wipe my mouth at the
same time don't take that out of context
everybody else
I mean well hundreds of gift machines
are being fired up across tumblr if
we're seein you know computers machine
specifically yeah there we go win winner
blue winter blue baby although you know
oh we unlocked another car sweet
what is it oh it doesn't go to think and
see what this is
all right yeah all right calm down
Gabe's Oh hot shot oh ha oh whoa that is
a big engine thank you you're welcome
all right thanks again everybody and as
always we will see you in the next
that [ __ ] yes we're the twins